round 4 of the Ziegfeld Rock the jewel  of st. Louis with three players tied for  first several others in the hunt the  best players in the world came into the  game out for blood tail and there Enda  paparazzi grab his chances when Aqaba  Nakamura made a terrible blunders and  the Russian player was able to finally  pocket his worst ways of the event it  was a battle royale and Santos Collison  seem to be dominating the position  against Mexican bhashya magrav but a  series of mistake by the world champion  allowed the French was the collectible  coins as well as dumplings his sole  possession of first place it's a day  before the rest day and the players will  be going all out for victory round 5  action coming up  [Music]